che cazzo ti si spende grande club se
meat boy and meat boy love che bella
cosa meglio di twilight riga e poi c'è
lo slider man mano nello sente nova di
laws dottor fair and that's why the two
states il ciao bello aspetta che sto
leggendo dato forfait ho detto che sto
leggendo mastronzo proibit meat boy
milan dai cuori ragazzo mio sto leggendo
e chi tappe bendtner e bastardo l'ha
rapita proprio sguardo in su sei è la
madonna che figo a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono fa vigenti
t'ammazzo la famiglia e oggi siamo super
meat boy che sarebbe un avete presente
tipo che mario mettetelo da parte fatto
presente tipo agricolo di toni mettete
la parte anche questo perché il
confronto non sono un cazzo però è anche
abbastanza lo è famoso
se però sei calmo zio i ragazzi che io
super meat boy l'avevo giocato tipo tre
anni fa più o meno non vorrei sbagliare
però lo avevo giocato malissimo nel
senso che non avevo fatto manco un
livello ci sta ancora il tizio figo come
cazzo ti sei permesso di picchiare una
donna stronzo ma che ti rovino talmente
tanto gli schiaffi che la parte più
bella del tuo corpo sarà il pancreas e
foreste foresta un altro gioco però non
volevo giocare a super meat boy ma va
bene lo stesso che mi ha mandato a
[ __ ]
cioè se io premuto shift mi manda
affanculo hai difficoltà aumentata si
tanto ciao bello assolutamente bf
un'altra ragazza no piazze ridicolo
ragazzi partiamo prima chi è che finché
si venga notte prova bene allora gift ok
ci siamo perfetto line non mi ricordo
bello non mi ricordo i comandi perché ho
giocato tipo secoli fa quindi non mi
ricorderò mai come si fanno le cose però
ragazzi ci si prova va bene allora
queste sono le parti facile fin qua è
fin qua ci sono ragazzi pare che quando
muori vedi tutti gli omini che bello
bravo di tutti gli uomini che quello
continua a picchiarmi la ragazza va bè
ragazzi questo è ancora semplice fino
adesso diventerà difficile pian piano ho
creato questo per provare a giocare per
vedere se siamo incompleti [ __ ]
o meno siamo completi [ __ ]
cos'è sta roba nuova veramente
ma no sapevo cosa ma c'era anche
l'ultima volta no a ciò solo tre vite
per vincere sarà perfetto come faccio a
saltarla joy possibile sì l'ho fatta ho
vinto bella così è una roba ma a livello
strano livello bonus pensato che ci
fosse stata bene era meglio che non lo
sapevo è una roba strana perché no no no
mi rimasta una vita e questo è più
semplice di quello di prima questo è
bello
ok no bravo bravo bravo ok il bello
ragazzi che non so anche che cosa sto
giocare diverso da super mito è una
specie di una merda devo saltare ce la
posso fare
ma porca va da sé tipo a vado a che va
dalla porca vada che gioco di merda mi
butto giù e vado ad no ecco bravo
perfetto adesso devo saltare più meno
lizzy [ __ ] da 1 a 215 ariane
è una roba allora in teoria dovrebbe
dovrebbe dovrebbe essere per persone con
un cervello cosa che io non ho fatti
tanti ragazzi e fottiamo cieli sta roba
tanto non era quello il gioco era un bon
cosa bones lo farò un'altra volta quando
sarò più bravo nord adesso diciamo ok
stanno arrivando le lame ecco vedi già
inizia a essere più difficile
stavo scherzando su quel cazzo di
scoiattolo si sta facendo inglobare
dalle le rondini bravo scoiattolo ok a
piano asi o tech perfetto sta diventando
un pochettino più allora ve lo dico
ragazzi più avanti diventerà una roba
infattibile ma veramente in fi questa è
una roba semplicissima in confronto
infatti sono un [ __ ] devo riuscire
ad arrivare l'altra parte senza n senza
crepare più volte devo riuscire a finire
si livelli magari in pochi minuti che
sia meno riesco a vedere una parte un po
più difficile declino per il fatto che
devi anche sfondare i muri tipo bravo
perfetto ora che sfasato tutto il muro
siamo a posto da perché mi faceva il
devasta casa e come secondo lavoro
quindi ho preso una pillola sono in
stato drogato non capito perché ho fatto
robe la madonna la madonna cosa ho fatto
i trick tutto lui a caso guardalo
madonna cruz vabbè basta basta datemi
dei premi grazie
ok piano eccolo no quello ma da chiamate
il 91 un'ambulanza è una roba che sacco
agosto crepando troppe volte 10 secondi
tipo ma serio come la per questo che
quando giusto un paio di volte quindi a
posto è una roba mi ha sentito lega
piano ok ok perfetto che ci sono i
scoiattoli sto gioco hanno capito il
senso va beh fate sega cioè degli spasmi
sto coniglio anche il coniglio sta male
una roba va bene senti zio bravo è morto
mi dispiace si è suicidato ma la mente
va bene così non da ricoh anzi mi stanno
sul culo cisco jato e bello non devo
dirlo bene adesso morirò per il resto
della mia vita che salto bellissimo ma a
che pro hugin a ragazzi c'è una supposta
in alto che devo prendere perché saleri
infilare nel culo ecco perfetto no
perchè se no non era contento lega
quindi a posto ok è quella [ __ ] la
chiami ragazza to piano piano
ok ok veloce no perché c'è una ragazzina
3 è veramente una tristezza di vita cioè
non ci sto credendo mai veloce ma ma dio
santo e il po perché questo è l'ultimo
livello reca poi non c'è più un cazzo in
teoria poi c'è l'altro la parte che più
difficile però almeno alla prima finiamo
bravo bravo il mio pene è fatta non
voglio sapere come non chiedere non fate
doman sono un deficiente ma voci ai
neuroni da tricheco è stata una roba
come cazzo sono morte
cerchiamo di avere un po più di neuroni
decenti adesso che è quindi piano bravo
no stavo cadendo di nuovo e poteva
essere tragica perché non scendi perché
c'è la mamma [ __ ] veloce veloce veloce
giu bravo veloce lo so ma perché non
scendere ma che possono fare più di così
è impossibile
c'è una ragazza lo sto passando da 20 a
[ __ ]
non è che era facile stavano riesco
neanche a finire questo ok ok adesso
adesso piano piano anzi no veloce veloce
sì
[Musica]
se dio santo è stato tragico ci guarda
che schifo ecco questo intendevo quando
quando ci sono troppi cosi bene è uno
stupro di massa comunque ragazzi ho
finito la prima borsa locked per fece il
boss e la roba bello questo anno questo
so io perfetto super meat boy piccolo
ragazzo carne che cosa fa
addio stoffa da fuoco qualcosa o mio dio
che faccia che c'aveva e scalta fratello
devo chiamare i pompieri ti faccio
arrestare ambulanze ne sono passate
prima e quindi alla madonna che cazzo
l'attestato stronzo di merda la mia ti
bacia sul retro fantastico ma il boss
sempre questo cambia di volta in volta
io non lo sapremo mai perché morirò
sempre ragazzi è bellissimo solo che è
un po stronzo mi sta sul culo sotto
l'attacco degli scoiattoli premier e che
ha bravi chiama sono utili allora sono
utili al bene perché sono morto ma ok ma
attaccata attaccate bravi una roba
fantastica e così è tanto sto cala
mignot che sto facendo ma non ci sono
dei check point casi impossibile ok
bravo bravo no ragazzino non vedo l'ora
di provarlo allora sentite è se riesco a
fini sta roba
poi si dovrebbero sbloccare gli altri
livelli che non oso pensare che cosa
cazzo possono essere non voglio saperlo
ma che chitarra possente che c'è di
sottofondo vai così che mi carica mai
così mai così vai così salta però salta
ai vai vai vai vai vai ma dove la
velocità la velocità la velocità adesso
ciò due chilometri di vantaggio sono
morto uguale e sono meat boy freccia
destra e freccia su barra spaziatrice
succedere io ho attivato qualcosa che mi
dice che cosa clicco cioè una roba tipo
cos'è sta roba
favia è un figo punto piangi ma grazie
zia torniamo su super mito ai ragazzi
che non ho capito lo stesso cesa mia
cosa sei serio ha salvato vero madonna
per un attimo avuto una cagata pazzesca
c'ha mai tornati borghi adryan
milioni riuscì a farsi appare
impossibile bravi sfogliate stavolta ci
dobbiamo riuscire magari senza
assistenti vocali o cagate ok grazie ai
vai vai vai che ti sta raggiungendo vai
che c'ha il pene duro da che impossibile
e non ci credo ragazzina roba e in
questo livello e as è qualcosa di
bye bye tira dio dio che si è fatto
no no no no no proprio no nella vita ci
siamo me lo sento che ci siamo me lo
sento che ci siamo melo dimension
sembrava niente ho sentito male avrò
bisogno di amplifon sì sì sì sì sì se la
vuoi quest'acqua così ti spegne non te
la do stronzo di morire devi è morto
chimiche crepa perché mi sta sul culo in
una maniera che non potete capire che
bello sguardo e vola lurido straw è
volato via
ma no ma no ragazzi ragazzi ragazzi
sveglia arriva su lega no lega sono
morti tutti sono morti un e vivo un e
vivo sono una cattiva persona non ce la
faccio e vabbè vabbè cazzoni che sei
morto duemila volte d'accordo ragazzi è
stato devo continuarlo perché dio mio è
la cosa più bella della storia se coi
ragazzi che volevo giocarlo ma non ho
mai fatto perché lo scoprirete tra poco
quando inizierò a lanciarle tastiere di
ragazzi con il primo episodio spero che
i video vi sia piaciuto e cosa solito se
video è piaciuto lasciato momento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e con
anni via trattare scrizione senso rischi
discreti cv da uno prossimo video bella
ragazza